- I love that there's a tribute
to John Mahoney who played your father.
Is that the name of the bar?
- Mahoney's Bar, yeah.
The baby's name is John.
The son, Daphne and Niles', aw, loved him.
- And Eddie.
Yeah, you have no idea.
I have...
- But yeah, John died a few years back
and I just thought, well,
we can't do the show again
without honoring John, we just can't
and it has to begin with
the fact that John is gone
and dad's gone, Martin's gone
and so then I become dad, you know?
- Oh my gosh.
Okay, my makeup artist will kill me.
(audience laughing)
I'm a contagious crier, so...
- Me too.
- I'm gonna be fine.
Okay, in Boston though, you're back there.
So do you think any "Cheers"
characters will come in
and out, do you think?
- No, no.
- No?
Don't let me down "Cheers" people!
(audience laughing)
I was like, "That would
be amazing, just one."
- The bar is closed.
The bar went out of business.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For whatever reason.
But I would like to see Diane come back.
Just for one of those reasons,
of Frazier being able
to put something to bed,
to end up with a nice thing between them.
- Closure.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and to kind of
just rediscover how much,
'cause when I first got the role,
the key to Frazier for me was
that he loved her with his whole heart,
that he loved with all of his being
and that actually defined who he is.
He's been that way ever since.
He just goes in
wholeheartedly with everything
and that's what makes him funny.
- Yeah, so witty, oh my gosh.